En los últimos tiempos han crecido como la
espuma las dudas, los mitos y, también, las
preocupaciones sobre cómo será el empleo
en el futuro, especialmente en los países
desarrollados.
La robótica, la inteligencia artificial,
la inmigración, la competencia internacional…
Según muchas personas vamos a tener que aconstrumbarnos a un futuro
donde el trabajo sea un lujo y
el desempleo masivo, la situación... normal
para la mayoría de las personas.
Un mundo, en definitiva, amigos, donde las
desigualdades serán mucho mayores y la precariedad
laboral una especie de cláusula irrenunciable
para quien tenga, ojo, la “suerte” de
poder trabajar.
Y… no solo eso.
Prácticamente las mismas personas que defienden
todas estas tesis, dicen también que si no
realizamos profundos cambios y ponemos freno
a este “frenético” desarrollo, el bienestar
de todos nosotros... estará en peligro.
Claro, si apenas hay trabajo y la riqueza
y la producción, se concentran en una reducida
pero poderosa oligarquía de grandes empresarios…
¿De qué viviremos? ¿Quién pagará impuestos?
¿Cómo diantres financiaremos el estado de
bienestar de tantas personas paradas o con
trabajos tan precarios?
Suena mal, ¿verdad? Casi parece que...como
decirlo, estamos a punto de enfrentarnos a
la tormenta perfecta.
Pues... precisamente son muchos de estos miedos
los que han favorecido la llegada a la política
de líderes tan populistas como Donald Trump
o Marine Le Pen, entre otros.
(Estos líderes políticos afirman que nuestras
sociedades o se están desmoronando o están
a punto de hacerlo; y que para impedirlo ellos
son nuestra única esperanza. Porque ellos
tienen la decisión de poner fin a un modelo
que nos ha conducido a este desastre.)
Claro, si hay una amenaza habrá que defenderse.
Y... no, no hablamos solo de los inmigrantes,
para nada.
“Amazon está haciendo mucho daño a los
minoristas contribuyentes. Pueblos, ciudades
y estados a lo largo de Estados Unidos están
siendo dañados, ¡se están perdiendo muchos
Pero, esperad un momento
¿Será verdad que estamos avanzando hacia
un futuro tan “oscuro”?
¿Será verdad que los robots nos quitarán
nuestros empleos y destruirán nuestra forma
de vida? ¿Acaso será cierto que si no nos
encerramos detrás de grandes muros correremos
el riesgo de perder nuestros trabajos?
Pues, bien, para responder a estas preguntas
y analizar qué hay de verdad en todas estas
cuestiones o todos estos mitos, vamos a fijarnos
en lo que está ocurriendo, claro, en nuestro mundo.
pero sobre todo en lo que está pasando en
la mayor potencia económica de la tierra,
en el país más influyente. Sí, en Estados
Unidos.
(¿EL FIN DEL EMPLEO?)
Coches autónomos; máquinas que son capaces
de aprender por sí mismas; fábricas sin
trabajadores, robots inteligentes… La ciencia
ficción parece estar convirtiéndose, día
tras día, en una realidad.
Y, ojo, toda esta ola tecnológica no ha hecho
sino apenas comenzar.
La nanotecnología, la biotecnología, la
ingeniería genética o la robótica prometen
cambiar para siempre el mundo que conocemos,
multiplicar la productividad y sustituir a
las personas.
Fijaos:
(En un Informe al Presidente en 2016, el Consejo
de Asesores Económicos de los Estados Unidos
estimó que, ni más ni menos, el 83% de los
empleos que pagaban menos de 20$ la hora podrían
ser automatizados en… poco tiempo).
Es decir, en otras palabras, que los países
que más rápido desarrollen y utilicen todo
esto de la robótica serán los primeros en
sufrir grandes pérdidas de empleo. Millones
y millones de nuevos parados.
Pero, un momento ¿Es este el futuro que nos
espera?
Evidentemente el futuro es por definición
incierto, pero... podemos fijarnos en lo que
ya está ocurriendo… porque… Sí, ya hay
robots, por ejemplo, en las fábricas..
Pues bien, si vamos a los datos, veremos que
la evidencia empírica nos dice… todo lo
contrario.
Atentos a este gráfico: los países que más
robots utilizan son, precisamente, los que
menos desempleo padecen.
Pues bien , todo esto tiene una explicación.
Muchas veces nos fijamos mucho en los puestos
de trabajo que desaparecen, pero no vemos
todos los nuevos empleos que se crean al mismo
tiempo.
(NUEVOS TIEMPOS, NUEVOS EMPLEOS)
Hasta ahora, ha sido en la industria donde
más robots se han utilizado.
De hecho, algunas compañías de coches como
Ford ya tienen líneas de montaje formadas
exclusivamente por robots, es decir, sin trabajadores.
Pues bien, la producción industrial de Estados
Unidos está prácticamente en niveles récord…
pero ¿qué ha pasado con los empleos industriales?
Mirad:
Sí, así es. Si en los años 40 la industria
generaba en Estados Unidos, 1 de cada 3 puestos
de trabajo hoy apenas genera 1 de cada 12
empleos ¡4 veces menos!
¿Quiere decir esto que no hay trabajo en
Estados Unidos? Para nada.
(Desde los años 40, la potencia norteamericana
ha generado más de 86 millones de nuevos
empleos en el sector servicios: transportes,
finanzas, entretenimiento, etcétera, etcétera.
De hecho, atentos, nunca antes en la historia
habían trabajado tantas personas en este país.)
Y ojo, estamos hablando de robótica, pero
el efecto de cualquier tecnología es equivalente.
Puede que ya no exista Blockbuster, que fue
la empresa más grande de alquiler de videojuegos
y películas, pero a cambio tenemos Netflix
o, sin ir más lejos, YouTube.
Y estas son, amigos, empresas que generan
un montón de puestos de trabajo.
También nos podemos fijar, en la industria
de las aplicaciones... en Australia.
¿Apps en Australia?, suena casi a broma ¿verdad?
Pues… esperad un momento, porque esta industria
ha creado más de 113.000 puestos de trabajo
en uno de los países más ricos y con más
calidad de vida de todo el mundo.
(Y... no solo es cosa de Australia… En Estados
Unidos este sector - que recordad es muy,
muy, muy nuevo, nació hace apenas 10 años
con el iPhone - ha creado más de 1 millón
y medio de empleos.
Bancos, supermercados, aseguradoras, empresas
de software… todos quieren tener listas
sus aplicaciones.. y todo eso significa nuevos
puestos de trabajo.)
Además, a medida que crece la productividad,
lo normal es que las horas de trabajo también
se reduzcan. Es decir, que gracias a la tecnología
y a los robots trabajaremos menos horas, y
eso son ¡buenas noticias!
(“Lo creas o no, en los próximos 30 años,
la gente sólo trabajará 4 horas al día
y tal vez 4 días a la semana. Ahora la gente
visita de media 30 lugares, dentro de 30 años
visitarán 300. Así que parar la globalización
es imposible y tenemos que estar preparados
para ello”)
Y por último, un detalle importante.
Hay quien, como Bill Gates, ha defendido que...
como los robots, al fin y al cabo, van a ocupar
puestos de trabajo que antes realizaban personas
de carne y hueso, pues... que hay que hacerles
pagar más impuestos.
Y ¿sabéis que? Creo, sinceramente, que esto
es una pésima idea.
Los robots no son más que máquinas y tecnología.
Y cuantas más máquinas y tecnología tengamos,
mejor viviremos. Los robots, amigos, reducen
los costes y con ellos el precio de las mercancías.
Gracias a ellos los consumidores podemos podemos
trabajar menos y comprar más.
Por todo ello, los gobiernos no tienen que
castigar la inversión, sino impulsarla. Sólo
así lograremos un mundo mejor para todos.
De verdad, poner nuevos impuestos a los robots…
no es una buena idea.
al fin y al cabo es retrasar un cambio inevitable,
Tenemos que prepararnos y sí, ahí es donde
casi todos los gobiernos están fallando.
Pero de eso hablaremos otro día.
PAREMOS LA GLOBALIZACIÓN
Los que seguís habitualmente VisualPolitik
ya conocéis la obsesión que “nuestro amigo”
Trump tiene... con China.
Y no se trata solo de China…
En el último año Trump ha acusado a Canadá,
a México, a Japón e, incluso, a Corea del
Sur, entre otros países, de competencia desleal
y de estar destruyendo puestos de trabajo
en Estados Unidos.
Por eso Trump quiere renegociar acuerdos comerciales,
impulsar políticas proteccionistas y llegado
el caso, fijar aranceles. Por ejemplo, en
la industria siderúrgica.
Claro que... sería el primer presidente de
Estados Unidos que utiliza algunas de estas
estrategias…
Sin ir más lejos, otro republicano, George
Bush, estableció en 2002 fuertes aranceles,
a las importaciones de acero.
“El presidente Bush llevó a cabo una de
las acciones federales más intensas en dos
décadas para proteger una gran industria
americana, imponiendo aranceles de hasta el
30% en la mayoría de los tipos de acero importados
a Estados Unidos desde Europa, Asia y Sudamérica”.
Y la verdad, el resultado no fue nada bueno.
Algunos estudios cuantifican en más de 200.000
empleos los puestos de trabajo que se perdieron
con los aranceles al acero.
Tal cual como lo escucháis: menos empleo
y menos competitividad.
También nos podemos fijar en… Argentina,
un país donde el proteccionismo tuvo este
resultado
Por supuesto menos exportaciones significa
menos empleo.
Pero... ahí no termina todo, para nada.
Es verdad que en las últimas dos décadas
la deslocalización de fábricas le ha hecho
a Estados Unidos perder muchos puestos de
trabajo…
pero en cierto modo gracias a ello países
como China han podido desarrollarse y hoy
sus empresarios están deseosos de entrar
e invertir en los Estados Unidos, la mayor
economía del mundo y un lugar seguro para
sus inversiones.
Y, cómo decimos por aquí, dicho y hecho.
(En 2016 las empresas chinas invirtieron casi
50.000 millones de dólares en Estados Unidos
y hoy ya dan trabajo, de forma directa, a
más de 140.000 estadounidenses., ¡9 veces
más que en 2009!)
Es el caso, por ejemplo, de este empresario
que veis, Cao Dewang,  un tipo
que en 2014 se gastó 700 millones de dólares
en rehabilitar una planta que General Motors
había cerrado en Ohio.
Y no se trata solo de las empresas chinas,
1 de cada 5 estadounidenses trabaja para empresas
extranjeras.
Y, ojo, recordad que como hemos visto antes,
nunca, nunca antes en la historia había habido
tantas personas trabajando en Estados Unidos.
Así que... todo eso de que la globalización
está destrozando nuestras económicas…
pues... cómo que no.
(LOS INMIGRANTES Y EL TRABAJO.)
Sin lugar a dudas, lo sabéis todos, esta
es una de las cuestiones más recurrentes,
especialmente en los Estados Unidos.
("Están tomando nuestro trabajo. Están tomando
nuestros trabajos en la industria. Están
tomando nuestro dinero. Nos están matando".
Donald Trump.)
Esto dice Donald, veamos que ocurre en la
vida real.
(En 2016, Estados Unidos obtuvo 6 premios nobeles
en Ciencia y Economía. Todos ellos fueron  ganados
por inmigrantes, personas nacidas en otro
país que hoy trabajan en Universidades de
Estados Unidos, algo habitual en la historia
de este país.)
No solo eso, los inmigrantes tienden a ser
más emprendedores, así que a pesar de suponer
sólo el 15% de la fuerza de trabajo en Estados
Unidos, están involucrados en 1 de cada 3
empresas nuevas que se crean en este país.
Y son, precisamente, las empresas nuevas las
que más hacen crecer el empleo.
Pero fijaos, hay dos tipos de inmigrantes.
Por un lado están los ilegales, que se ocupan
de las tareas más físicas o de las trabajos
que los estadounidenses no quieren realizar.
Por otro están los inmigrantes legales, de
los cuales 1 de cada 2 tiene estudios universitarios,
una proporción muy superior a la de las personas
nacidas en Estados Unidos.
Es decir, estos inmigrantes aportan mucha
materia gris, son emprendedores y en muchos
casos han sido los responsables de grandes
proyectos de éxito.
(Procter & Gamble, Goldman Sachs, Yahoo; Google,
Tesla; AT&T, Intel, ebay, IBM, Citigroup;
UPS; Oracle , Amazon o incluso Apple han sido
algunas de las muchas compañías fundadas
o cofundadas por inmigrantes o hijos de inmigrantes.)
Así que, cómo veis, lo mejor de todo es
que los inmigrantes no solo no quitan empleos
en Estados Unidos, sino que, incluso, los
crean.
Pues bien, como veis muchos de los mitos que
tratan de convencernos de que nuestros modos
de vida están en peligro no se corresponden
del todo con la evidencia.
Pero ahora, turno para ti: ¿tienes miedo a ser
sustituido en poco tiempo por un Robot? Déjanos
tus respuestas en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta.
Si te ha gustado el vídeo dale a like y no
olvides suscribirte al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.